liftoff was a Cornish dream Cosmic girl
carrying Aloft the UK's ambition to be a
space-faring nation under its wing a
rocket carrying nine satellites and out
over the Atlantic its engines fired it
looks to be a successful ignition a
perfect launch
but then from the edge of space came the
message Nuki we have a problem
welcome back everyone it appears that
launcher one has suffered an anomaly
which will prevent us from making orbit
for this mission
back at cornwall's Spaceport the news
was broken to a devastated team
something went wrong with the Rocket's
engine and it never quite made it into
orbit
the team did a phenomenal job but we had
an issue and we're going to find out
what went wrong and we're gonna fix it
two and a half thousand people came to
watch the first satellite launch from
Western Europe
but the Fizz went flat I feel guarded
for them put in all that hard work and
it's just not come to fruition has it
get up all the way
Spaceport Cornwall proved it can launch
rockets from a normal airport and it
will try again but disappointment first
time around is hard awful
I'm not gonna lie it's it's just like
it's gutting it was all we all heard at
different times
um so once we kind of all got together
there were tears
um and it was very upsetting only the
United States builds more satellites
than Britain determination to have a UK
launch base in Cornwall and later this
year Scotland is undimmed around 100
000 satellites are expected to be
launched globally by the end of the
decade this is about trying to capture
some of that market UK spaceports could
add 3.8 billion pounds to the economy
over the next eight years
but space is hard success far from
guaranteed